Film Courage: Your movie FOR THE LOVE OF GEORGE,
did you intend to have the crowdfunding campaign
be the sole source of production funds or
did you have other ideas?
Nadia Jordan, director, producer, actor: No.
The crowdfunding campaign at the start…I
didn’t know if I was going to make a short
or a feature.
So we did the crowdfunding campaign and kind
of just threw it out there to see what would
happen and it was 7 weeks of extremely hard
work.
And at the end of it we got a certain amount
of money and it was a lot of money in which
to make a short, but not near enough in which
to make a feature.
But at that point I didn’t want to make
a short and waste it on a short.
So many people I know were saying “You can’t
make a feature, your first feature.
You have to make a short first.”
What rule book says anywhere that you have
to make a short first?
And so many people that I knew had made a
short and regretted it and they are now using
that as a funding pitch for a feature.
And so at that point I thought I really want
to make a feature, you know?
Let’s go after that.
And this script was worked on and got better
and better.
And the more it improved the more I wanted
to make a better and better feature and wanted
to wait.
So yeah, it was then something that I then
had to look outside of crowdfunding and start
having meetings and pitching people and like
I say, everyone in Los Angeles is trying to
do that.
It’s fairly easy to get in doors in LA because
everyone is worried about missing the next
best thing.
It’s a lot harder to get anyone to commit
or get funding or that side of it.
I really tried everything.
Like I would go to investors and film financiers
in LA and I had a few interesting meetings
where they would want to change the script
and they wanted to change the husband and
the husband should be…(this was one male
financier that I went to see) had very strong
ideas about how Poppy [the protagonist in
FOR THE LOVE OF GEORGE] toward her husband
which I didn’t listen to at all and he didn’t
finance the film.
But eventually you try everything.
I was getting all of these creative ideas
about how I was going to do funding and I
was going to go to the country club and fundraising
meetings and talk to people about how they
can get involved in film, which I actually
tried doing that.
None of it worked.
But I was really trying to get creative and
go outside of the box in terms of getting
money within LA because at that time I decided
I didn’t want to give the rights up.
I didn’t want to have someone else make
it through their production company.
I wanted to have someone give me money to
make it through my production company.
It was a bit further down the line I realized
again ‘Well, if I want this I’m going
to try and have to get the money myself,’
and that’s what I did.
Film Courage: Was this from a series of investors
(aside from the crowdfunding)?
Nadia Jordan: Yeah, I think we had about 4
or 5 investors.
And you know, it was really about relationship
building and finding people who could relate
to either the subject or friends of other
investors or things like that.
It was a very long process and very time-consuming
and I can’t tell you the amount of emails
I sent out (thousands) trying to find ways
to raise the money.
But I was very fortunate in the end it all
came together and I had a couple of actually
females in particular that believed in the
project and believed in me and yeah, I’m
very grateful for that.
Film Courage: I almost envision Poppy’s
character in sort of the situation you were
going through in that everybody is in her
ear kind of like telling her what to do and
how it should be, I find that interesting.
How did you decipher “Okay, I’m going
to listen to this person.
This person is probably very knowledgable
and I’m sure they have great intentions,
but I don’t think this is for me.”
How did you know whom to listen to?
Nadia Jordan: I think I just have a very strong
belief if you want to do something that badly
and not something that is completely delusional,
than you can achieve it.
And I had people who said “Oh, you know
you can’t do a film about George Clooney
unless you have a budget of 10 million.
And I’m like…what?
Sometimes I just think where do these people
get this stuff from?
Who taught them that because it’s just blatantly
not true.
I don’t know, I’m just a believer that
if you really put everything into it unless
you have some really random, stupid idea,
than why can’t you do it?
You know, who is to tell me I can’t and
if I’m not getting anywhere than maybe I’ll
rethink it, but let me try it.
Let me try doing it my way.